We're now going to take a quick look at what Chaos clothing is to better understand the technology that we are going to be utilizing.
Now, ChaosCloth is the name for the solver that UE5 uses to simulate complex cloth interaction.
This clothing solver makes integrations lightweight and extensible because we have access to the simulation data.
In the image right here, what we're actually looking at are the individual simulation points for a flag that we will be creating here in a little bit.
This just goes to show you the complexity that we are getting with the Chaos clothing simulation.
Now, when you are creating any type of geometry for your Chaos clothing,
there's going to be a certain workflow that needs to be adhered to, and basically it's going to work like this.
Inside of our Digital Content Creation Tool, or DCC, we're going to authorize our geometry, and then we're going to export that as an FBX.
Once we have that FBX file and we import that into Unreal, we're then going to create our clothing files,
and then we're going to use the tools inside of Unreal Engine to change how everything for our clothing reacts to physics.
And we'll keep kind of redoing this check. Does it work the way we want it?
Let's go back and adjust. So what this is getting at is that we only really need our Digital Content Creation Tools to actually create that initial piece of clothing.
Everything else that we're going to be doing is going to be done inside of the editor,
and this makes this iterative workflow of making a little change and test very, very quick,
because we don't ever have to go back to another program. We can always do everything in the engine,
test it right away, and make sure that we're getting the results that we want.